we will rename our schools and
boulevards
not after Communists but after Great
American Patriots
we will get rid of bad and ugly
buildings and return to the Magnificent
classical style of Western Civilization
wow
we will support baby boomers
and we will support baby bonuses
for a new baby boom how does that sound
that sounds pretty I want a baby boom
there's this thing called the child tax
credit which Joe Biden and Democrats
would like to make permanent a higher
tax credit for children which in a way
is kind of what Trump is talking about
although the the child tax credit isn't
to encourage people to have children
it's to provide financial support for
those who do but Republicans are against
making that permanent